Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. God of the people and of kings of cities of the countryside, of Luther, of Calvin, the children of Israel, remember the times when the sinister tyrants crushed underfoot the rights of the French. The time not so long ago when wicked ministers deceived peoples and kings. Princes, nobles, bishops swam in opulence. The people shuddered under their wealth. Their palaces were cemented with the blood of the oppressed, the tears of misery.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。人民与城市国王之神、乡村之神、路德、加尔文、以色列之子啊，请记住那些凶恶的暴君将法国人的权利踩在脚下的时代。不久前，邪恶的大臣们欺骗了人民和国王。亲王、贵族、主教们沐浴在奢华之中。人民在他们的财富下颤抖。他们的宫殿是用受压迫者的鲜血、悲惨的眼泪浇筑而成的。
That was the song of the 14th of July, which was written by the director of the Paris opera, François-Joseph Gossec. And the words were by a poet called Marie-Joseph Chénier. And it was written to celebrate the second Bastille Day. So that's the 14th of July, 1791. And Dominic, I'm guessing that most of our listeners will have realised from this preamble that we're back with the French Revolution, our old friend, because we did our first series, didn't we, to coincide with the Paris Olympics, but they're long gone. But we're continuing the story because we want to do this in sufficient depth that we can give the subject the attention that it deserves,
那是7月14日的歌曲，由巴黎歌剧院总监弗朗索瓦-约瑟夫·戈塞克谱曲。歌词由一位名叫玛丽-约瑟夫·谢尼埃的诗人所写。这首歌是为了庆祝第二个巴士底日而写的。也就是1791年7月14日。多米尼克，我猜我们的大多数听众从这段开场白中就已经意识到，我们又回到了法国大革命这个老朋友身边，因为我们制作第一个系列节目时，正值巴黎奥运会期间，但那已经是过去时了。不过我们要继续这个故事，因为我们希望对这个主题进行足够的深入探讨，给予它应有的关注，
and which we didn't when we did our first treatment of it. And we dispatched it in a single episode in 50 minutes. Yeah, not anymore, Tom. Those are very distant days. So hi, everybody. This is season two, isn't it, Tom? Yeah. It's the second season of the French Revolution. And so we're kicking off at the Champs-Élysées, which is on the western side of Paris, on the 14th of July 1791. So this was a huge public occasion, Bastille Day. And the Champs-Élysées had this kind of earthen stadium with this kind of great embankments with the grandstands. And they had an altar of the fatherland as they'd had a year before.
而我们在第一次处理它时并没有做到这一点。我们在50分钟内的一集节目里就把它打发了。是的，不再是这样了，汤姆。那已经是遥远的日子了。所以大家好，这是第二季，对吧，汤姆？是的。这是法国大革命的第二季。所以我们从巴黎的香榭丽舍大街开始，也就是1791年7月14日的巴黎西侧。所以这是一个巨大的公共场合，巴士底日。香榭丽舍大街有这种土造的体育场，有这种带看台的巨大路堤。他们还有一个祖国祭坛，就像一年前那样。
And thousands of people turned up. But it was quite different this time, 1791. And that hymn tells the story a bit. So it's all about shuddering under the wealth of tyrants and blood and people being crushed underfoot and stuff. But a year before, in 1790, the same authors had just written a te deum. Yeah, so hymns and all very Catholic and stuff. Yeah, that's one element of change and then the other is in 1790 so a year after the fall of the bastille louis xvi had been there and he had sworn an
成千上万的人涌了出来。但这次大不相同，1791年。那首赞美诗在一定程度上讲述了这个故事。所以这里面全是关于在暴君的财富、鲜血和被踩在脚下的人们之类的事情下颤抖。但在前一年，即1790年，同样的作者刚刚写了一首赞美诗（Te Deum）。是的，所以有赞美诗，而且都非常天主教化之类的内容。是的，这是一个改变的元素，另一个改变是，在1790年，也就是巴士底狱陷落一年后，路易十六曾到过那里，他宣誓效忠
oath to the constitution and he had really been the star of the show in 1791 he's not there there are no royal flags there are no royal symbols and on the altar, the word king has been literally scrubbed out. So there's that big inscription which says the nation, the law. And then it says the and then there's a missing word because they've taken out the word king. Yeah. I mean, just to say, I mean, one thing that immediately strikes me about those words, we still have this thing that it's wicked ministers deceiving the people and kings. So the king, he's not grouped in with that list of people who are swimming in opulence, the princes, the nobles and the bishops.
宪法，而且他确实是那场演出的主角，但在1791年，他不在那里，没有皇家旗帜，没有皇家象征，在祭坛上，“国王”这个词被字面意义上地抹去了。所以有一个巨大的铭文，上面写着国家、法律。然后写着“the”，然后漏掉了一个词，因为他们把“国王”这个词去掉了。我的意思是，顺便说一句，我从这些词中立即想到的第一件事是，我们仍然有这样一种观点，即是邪恶的大臣们欺骗了人民和国王。所以国王并没有被归入那些沐浴在奢华中的人（亲王、贵族和主教）的名单中。
So there is still a kind of phantasmal sense of respect for the king. Yeah, they're very phantasmal, I would say. Very phantasmal, yeah. So the reason we thought it would be interesting to kick off here, the Chandamasse, is that just three days after this great celebration, there will be gunshots and screaming and bodies piling up on one of the bloodiest days of the revolution, a turning point in French history, the massacre at the Champs-Élysées. So that is to come in today's episode. But Tom, maybe before we get there, we should remind ourselves, we should have a sort of HBO style recap. What happened in season one?
所以对国王仍然有一种虚幻的尊重感。是的，它们非常虚幻，我会这么说。非常虚幻，是的。所以我们认为从这里（战神广场）开始会很有趣的原因是，在这个盛大庆祝活动仅仅三天后，将会有枪声、尖叫声和尸体堆积，这是大革命中最血腥的日子之一，也是法国历史上的一个转折点，即战神广场大屠杀。所以这将在今天的节目中呈现。但是汤姆，也许在我们到达那里之前，我们应该提醒自己，我们应该来一个HBO风格的回顾。第一季发生了什么？
In season one of the French Revolution. So listeners will remember that at the heart of the revolution, there were three things that collided. So one was a financial and political crisis, France running out of money. Number two was a kind of social crisis, people starving because of freak weather events and so on. And number three, probably the element of this interests you most, Tom, is the sort of cultural moment. Lots of abstract nouns. Yeah. People being obsessed with virtue, with the Roman Republic, with the idea of purity.
在法国大革命第一季中。所以听众会记得，在大革命的核心，有三件事发生了碰撞。首先是财政和政治危机，法国资金耗尽。第二种是某种社会危机，由于反常的天气事件等原因，人们挨饿。第三，可能最让你感兴趣的元素，汤姆，就是某种文化时刻。很多抽象名词。是的。人们对美德、对罗马共和国、对纯洁的理念着迷。
And of course, Champ de Mars means, you know, it's the campus marshes. It's named after the place where the Roman people in the Republic would gather to celebrate their civic identity. And as we will see, running right through season two is the same obsession with Rome and the lessons of Roman history, so important for the French revolutionaries. So listeners will remember that to try and cope with all this, Louis XVI had very grudgingly recalled the Estates General, this sort of supposedly ancient assembly of the French people. That had declared itself the National Assembly while it was meeting. The disorder on the streets went out of control, culminating in the stormy Bastille. Then we had an episode that you did, Tom, about these market
当然，战神广场（Champ de Mars）的意思是，你知道的，它是战神校场（Campus Martius）。它是以共和国时期的罗马人民聚集在一起庆祝其公民身份的地方命名的。正如我们所看到的，贯穿第二季始终的是对罗马的同样痴迷以及罗马历史的教训，这对于法国革命者来说非常重要。所以听众会记得，为了应对这一切，路易十六非常勉强地召集了三级会议，这是一种所谓的古老的法国人民会议。它在开会时宣布自己为国民议会。街头骚乱失控，最终导致了暴风雨般的巴士底狱事件。然后我们有了你制作的一集节目，汤姆，关于这些市场
women marching on Versailles, effectively dragging the royal family back to Paris. Then you have this great fever of reform, of rebooting France, which included, most controversially, this attack on the independence and the privileges of the French clergy. Yeah, people probably have been struck by the mention of Luther and Calvin in that passage that I read right at the start of the show. And that's a reminder that I think that there are elements of the Reformation in what is happening in France, and that's what lots of devout Catholics think. There is an anxiety that the revolution is essentially a replay of what happened with Luther and Calvin, and it's still current two years on
妇女向凡尔赛进军，实际上把王室拖回了巴黎。然后你就会看到这股伟大的改革热潮，重塑法国，其中最具争议的是对法国神职人员的独立性和特权的发难。是的，人们可能对我在节目开头朗读的那段话中提到路德和加尔文印象深刻。这提醒人们，我认为在法国正在发生的事情中包含着宗教改革的元素，这也是许多虔诚的天主教徒所认为的。人们有一种担忧，即大革命本质上是路德和加尔文事件的重演，在巴士底狱陷落两年后，这仍然具有现实意义。
from the fall of the Bastille. Absolutely it is, and it's extremely controversial out in the countryside. So to move forward to the summer of 1791, by the summer of 1791, actually very few of these things have really got better. So prices are very high. People are still hungry. A lot of the problems have not yet been fixed. But there has been a definite change in the cultural temperature. Paris has become drenched in politics. People are reading out newspapers and cafes. People are wearing patriotic, tricolor cockades in their hats, all of that kind of stuff. So that coincides with the tone of public life becoming much more fractious and polarized. And it's against that background, as we ended the climax of the first season, Louis and Marion Toinette deciding that they would make a break for it and escape Paris.
绝对是这样，而且在乡村地区极具争议。所以快进到1791年夏天，到1791年夏天，实际上这些事情中很少有真正好转的。所以物价非常高。人们依然饥饿。很多问题还没有解决。但文化氛围确实发生了变化。巴黎已经浸透了政治气息。人们在咖啡馆里朗读报纸。人们在帽子里佩戴爱国的三色帽徽，诸如此类的事情。这与公共生活变得更加激化和极化的基调不谋而合。正是在这种背景下，正如我们第一季的高潮部分所结束的那样，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特决定突破重围，逃离巴黎。
They decided to flee to the eastern border where they would collect troops and probably march on the capital. But they were intercepted at Varennes and brought back by this huge, jeering crowd. And then they arrived in the city to a sort of terrifying silence. Nobody taking their hats off. Yeah, nobody, no gestures of respect at all. And then we ended with the gates of the Tuileries Palace literally clanging shut behind them while the crowd kind of lays into their bodyguards and tries to tear their bodyguards apart. So that's the recap.
他们决定逃往东部边境，在那里集结军队，并可能向首都进军。但他们在瓦雷讷被拦截，并被大量发出嘘声的人群带了回来。然后他们在一片可怕的沉默中抵达了这座城市。没有人脱帽。是的，没有任何表示尊重的姿态。然后我们以杜伊勒利宫的大门在他们身后砰然关闭而结束，同时人群殴打他们的保镖并试图把他们的保镖撕成碎片。这就是回顾。
And now let's literally continue from where we left off. Season two, part one. Season two. So the gates have closed. And as Louis looks out at the city, what he sees is a city that has completely turned against him since the news of his attempted escape. So it's not just that he had tried to run away. It is that he had left a letter in which he said, I was lying all along.
现在让我们接着刚才的地方继续。第二季，第一部分。第二季。大门关闭了。当路易望向这座城市时，他看到的是一座自从他企图逃跑的消息传出后就彻底与他反目成仇的城市。所以这不仅仅是因为他试图逃跑。而是他留下了一封信，信中说：“我一直都在撒谎。
I hate you. I hate the revolution. I wish you nothing but ill. Exactly. That's exactly it. And while he's been gone, the press, which previously had been very much this kind of stuff about the king has been misled by treacherous ministers. What do they call him? Papa. Le bon papa.
我恨你们。我恨大革命。我对你们只有厌恶。”完全正确。就是这样。当他离开时，此前曾大量刊登诸如“国王是被叛徒大臣误导的”之类言论的媒体——他们是怎么称呼他的？爸爸。好爸爸（Le bon papa）。
Le bon papa, exactly. All of this kind of stuff. That has vanished. And now they call him a traitor, a coward, Louis the false so if you look at some of those papers the analpolitik which was the most popular newspaper in these clubs that sprung up around the provinces allied to the central jacobin club or kind of revolutionary club in paris he deserted the throne the capital the empire and by this cowardly defection intended to come back with foreign executioners to rule over 25 million corpses they're're not wrong, really.
好爸爸，完全正确。所有这些东西。都已经消失了。现在他们称他为叛徒、懦客、虚伪的路易。所以如果你看看其中一些报纸，《大陆政治报》（L'Ami du Patrie），它是这些在雅各宾中央俱乐部或巴黎某种革命俱乐部周围涌现的省份俱乐部中最受欢迎的报纸：他背叛了王位、首都、帝国，并打算带着外国刽子手回来统治25具尸体。他们其实并没有说错。
No, they're not wrong. I mean, that was his plan. Yes. Effectively. This is the thing. We'll be talking a lot about conspiracy theories in the next couple of episodes, about conspiracy theories and paranoid suspicions. And yet the truth is they're right.
不，他们没有说错。我的意思是，这就是他的计划。是的。实际上就是这样。就是这样。在接下来的几集里，我们将大量讨论阴谋论，讨论阴谋论和偏执的猜疑。然而事实是，他们是对我的。
I mean, there literally was a conspiracy. Exactly. And that's so important in everything that follows, explains the climate of fear, of suspicion, and the belief that basically, you know, if you're living in a world where people are conspiring, you'd be better off killing your enemies
我的意思是，这确实是一个阴谋。完全正确。这在随后的所有事情中都至关重要，它解释了恐惧、怀疑的氛围，以及这样一种信念：基本上，你知道的，如果你生活在一个人们在密谋的世界里，你最好在敌人杀死你之前
before they kill you. That's the dynamic at the absolute center of what will follow. And the aggression, the sheer aggression, which of course draws on what you talked about
杀死你的敌人。这就是随后一切事物绝对核心的动力。这种攻击性，纯粹的攻击性——当然，这借鉴了你所谈论的内容——
at the very beginning of the first season, the torrent of invective against Louis and particularly Marie Antoinette. This is now turbocharged by the flight to Varennes. So there's a radical paper called Père Duchesne, which was edited by this incredibly aggressive
第一季刚开始时，对路易尤其是玛丽·安托瓦内特的恶毒攻击。现在，瓦雷讷逃亡事件让这一切得到了极大的强化。所以有一份名为《杜申神父报》的激进报纸，由一位非常激进的
journalist called Hébert. Some people may be familiar with a faction called the Hébertistes who are going to run into trouble later on. And he wrote, you are no longer my king. You're no longer my king. You're nothing but a cowardly deserter. We will stuff you into Charenton prison. But also a lunatic asylum.
名叫埃贝尔（Hébert）的记者编辑。有些人可能对一个名为“埃贝尔派”（Hébertistes）的派系很熟悉，他们稍后会遇到麻烦。他写道：“你不再是我的国王。你不再是我的国王。你不过是一个懦弱的逃兵。我们要把你塞进沙朗通（Charenton）监狱。”也是一个精神病院。
A lunatic asylum, yeah, exactly. We will stuff you into Charenton and your whore into the hôpital. And your whore is Marie-Antoinette, the queen. And the hôpital is where prostitutes are sent. Yeah, exactly. So during all this time, there's also been a sense in which the common people have been
一个精神病院，是的，完全正确。我们要把你塞进沙朗通，把你的婊子塞进医院。你的婊子就是王后玛丽·安托瓦内特。而医院就是关押妓女的地方。是的，完全正确。所以在整个这段时间里，普通民众也有一种
emboldened as never before. So we will hear a lot in the next few episodes about a group of people called the sans-culottes, working class people who don't wear breeches and stockings but wear trousers. And we have had, in the last few days, there's been so much panic about the flights of Iran. There have been groups of them, kind of impromptu militias, armed often with pikes or with makeshift weapons, taken to the streets. They had, while Louis had been gone, besieged the National Assembly, not aggressively, but because they wanted to be let inside to swear oaths to pledge their loyalty to the revolution. So on the one hand, they've done that. And on the other hand, they've been rampaging through the streets,
前所未有的被赋权感。所以在接下来的几集里，我们会听到很多关于一个名为“无套裤汉”（sans-culottes）的群体，即那些不穿马裤和长筒袜而是穿裤子的工人阶级。在过去的几天里，人们对瓦雷讷逃亡事件感到了极大的恐慌。其中有几组人，某种即兴民兵，通常携带长矛或权宜之武，走上了街头。在路易离开期间，他们包围了国民议会，不是出于攻击性，而是因为他们想进去宣誓效忠大革命。一方面，他们这样做了。另一方面，他们在街头横冲直撞，
smashing images of the king, his statues, his busts, ripping down pub signs, ripping down street signs, anything that has the kind of taint of monarchy. So kind of virtuous and principled, but simultaneously quite fun. Well, simultaneously quite fun, but also potentially very frightening. Yeah. If you're a lawyer by, you know, if you're somebody who prizes authority, stability and all those kinds of things. But I think if you've been raised in the shadow of the authority of the crown,
砸毁国王的画像、雕像、半身像，撕毁酒吧招牌、路标，任何带有君主制气息的东西。所以既有美德和原则，但同时又相当有趣。嗯，同时相当有趣，但也可能非常吓人。是的。如果你按本性来说是一个律师的话，如果你是一个珍视权威、稳定和所有这些东西的人。但我认为，如果你是在王权权威的阴影下长大的，
to be intimidated by it, and then you have a license by the behavior of the king, but also the sense that you are part of a large number of people who feel this, there must be a kind of giddy sense of excitement. Oh, I think there is. Yeah. You know, the thrill of almost blasphemy in toppling these statues. I think we talked in the first French Revolution series about how, if you miss the fact that for lots of people, this is quite good fun.
并因此受到震慑，然后你得到了国王行为的许可，同时也意识到你是感受到这一点的庞大群体中的一员，那一定有一种令人眩晕的兴奋感。哦，我认为是的。是的。你知道，推翻这些雕像几乎具有亵渎神明的刺激感。我想我们在第一季法国大革命系列中谈到过，如果你忽略了对很多人来说这其实挺有趣的事实，
All of these marches on Versailles, these great public spectacles. Yeah. You know, a lot of people, as we will see, treat these political moments as a kind of carnival. You can throw off the shackles of everyday convention and you can go around smashing stuff up and having a fine old time. And a lot of people, particularly young men, I think find that very invigorating. They always do in history, but the French revolution
所有这些向凡尔赛的进军，这些盛大的公众奇观。是的。你知道的，正如我们将看到的，很多人把这些政治时刻当作一种狂欢。你可以卸下日常常规的枷锁，四处砸东西，过得很开心。我认为很多人，尤其是年轻男子，会觉得这非常令人振奋。他们在历史上总是这样，但法国大革命
is a really good example of that. Well, kind of high-minded vandalism. Yes. I mean, you get the best of both worlds, don't you? Yeah, you do indeed. So the question now is what will happen to the king? France has never been a very Republican country. There have been Republicans, but they have been a tiny, tiny minority. And Republicanism, even in 1789, 1790, has never been more than a real kind of minority sport. But now, in the last few days since Louis' flight to Varennes, more and more people have been saying, you know, maybe the whole institution, it's not just louis that's the problem it's the institution that's the problem the club that has been instrumental in this is a club called the cordelier club that met on the left bank in the
是一个非常好的例子。嗯，某种高尚的破坏行为。是的。我的意思是，你两全其美，不是吗？是的，确实如此。所以现在的问题是国王会怎样？法国从来都不是一个非常共和的国家。曾经有过共和党人，但他们是极少数极少数。而且即使在1789年、1790年，共和主义也从未超过真正的少数派运动。但现在，在路易逃往瓦雷讷以来的过去几天里，越来越多的人说，你知道的，也许整个体制，不仅路易是个问题，体制才是问题所在。在这方面发挥重要作用的俱乐部是一个名为“科德利埃俱乐部”（Cordelier Club）的俱乐部，它在左岸的
heart of the kind of publishing district and the theater district it had a very radical populist tone its most famous members were people who we've talked about before or will be featuring very heavily so a guy called camille de moulin radical journalist who we've talked about before or will be featuring very heavily. So a guy called Camille Desmoulins, radical journalist. Who we featured in the previous series. Exactly, who's the hero of Hilary Mantel's novel, The Place of Greater Safety. A chap called Jean-Paul Marat, formerly of Newcastle. Skin problem. Skin problem.
出版区和剧院区的中心开会。它有着非常激进的平民主义基调。它最著名的成员是我们以前谈论过或将大量出现的人——一个名叫卡米尔·德穆兰（Camille Desmoulins）的人，我们之前谈论过或将大量出现的激进记者。一个名叫让-保罗·马拉（Jean-Paul Marat）的人，前纽卡斯尔人。皮肤问题。皮肤问题。
Another skin complaint person, Georges Danton, who we haven't really talked about before, who's this great, titanic, earthy, brilliant speaker and organiser who will play a very big part in the revolution. He's basically Gérard Depordieu, isn't he? Well, he's also, to a degree, he's you, Dominic. Oh, Tom, so kind. I've got lovely skin, though. That's the difference.
另一个有皮肤病的人，乔治·丹东（Georges Danton），我们以前没有怎么谈论过，他是一个伟大、泰坦般、朴实、出色的演说家和组织者，将在大革命中扮演非常重要的角色。他基本上就是热拉尔·德帕迪约（Gérard Depardieu），对吧？嗯，他在某种程度上也是你，多米尼克。哦，汤姆，太友善了。不过我有漂亮的皮肤。这就是区别。
Yeah. Well, it's not on every point, but a man of great principle. And appetite. Donson was married to like a 12-year-old or something when he was executed. So let's not go there. Right. So the Cordillier Club, within hours of the King's flight, has been arguing, okay, enough now.
是的。嗯，并非在每一点上都是如此，但（他是一个）充满原则的人。还有胃口。丹东被处决时，娶了一个大约12岁左右的妻子。所以我们还是别提这个了。好的。因此，在国王逃跑后的几个小时内，科德利埃俱乐部一直在争论，好吧，现在够了。
The National Assembly should pull the plug and let's declare France a republic. And in the next few weeks, the Cordillier Club and other radical clubs bombard the National Assembly should pull the plug and let's declare France a republic. And in the next few weeks, the Cordillier Club and other radical clubs bombard the National Assembly with petitions saying, you've got to scrap the monarchy now. You know, Louis has shown he can't be trusted. So the decision lies with the National Assembly, and we should perhaps recap a bit to remember what that was.
国民议会应该拔掉插头，宣布法国为共和国。在接下来的几周里，科德利埃俱乐部和其他激进俱乐部轰炸国民议会，要求废除君主制。国民议会应该拔掉插头，宣布法国为共和国。在接下来的几周里，科德利埃俱乐部和其他激进俱乐部用请愿书轰炸国民议会，要求现在就废除君主制。你知道，路易已经证明他是不可信的。所以决定权在于国民议会，我们也许应该回顾一下以前的内容来记住那是什么。
Remember that Louis had called the Estates General, and that had met in 1789. They had declared themselves a National Assembly, dissolving the boundaries between the three estates. The priests, the nobles and the common people. Exactly. But what's actually now happened is the nobles and the priests have all gone home. They're gutted about what's happening, by and large. And not only have they gone home, most of the commons have gone home because they didn't expect that they would be there for two years. Most of them are massively overworked, stressed, deluged with correspondence and petitions from their constituents.
记住路易召集了三级会议，并于1789年开会。他们宣布自己为国民议会，打破了三个等级之间的界限。神职人员、贵族和平民。完全正确。但现在实际发生的是，贵族和神职人员都回家了。总的来说，他们对正在发生的事情感到痛心。不仅他们回家了，大多数平民也回家了，因为他们没有料到自己会待两年。他们大多数人都严重过度工作、压力山大，被选民的信件和请愿书淹没。
And they've basically just given up. So there's only the 400 kind of hardcore deputies left. And they are trying to completely reboot France, to rewrite the government structures, the tax code, the law codes, and to write a new constitution. And they are absolutely worn out. In fact, from this point onwards, in this whole story running to when we finish the French Revolution, who knows when that will be, 2029, everybody is just constantly tired and half drunk. They're just absolutely exhausted. And also, I mean, kind of quite young as well. So it's increasingly becoming a young man's game. It is exactly. It's young, drunk, inexperienced men. Yes, exactly. And also
他们基本上已经放弃了。所以只剩下400名左右的坚定核心代表。他们正试图彻底重启法国，重写政府结构、税法、法典，并起草一部新宪法。他们绝对筋疲力尽。事实上，从这一刻起，在这个贯穿我们完成法国大革命（谁知道那会是什么时候，2029年）的整个故事中，每个人都只是经常感到疲惫和半醉。他们绝对精疲力竭。而且，我的意思是，也相当年轻。所以这越来越成为年轻人的游戏。确实如此。它是年轻、醉酒、经验不足的男人们。是的，完全正确。还有
frightened men. So these deputies who had been elected in 1789, they didn't think they'd be there two years later. I mean, they thought they were going to Versailles, of course, not to Paris. So they're in the centre of Paris now, and they are surrounded by people with trousers on and pikes who are sort of smashing up street signs and things. There are constant bread riots and brawls in the markets and all of this. And actually, the deputies, we can tell from their correspondence when they write home, they say, I actually don't feel safe anymore. I'm genuinely concerned about my personal safety. And to add to that, at the back of their minds from this point onwards, summer of 1791, there is a lesson in what can happen when order falls apart completely.
受惊吓的人们。所以这些在1789年当选的代表们，他们没想到两年后自己还会在那里。我的意思是，他们以为自己要去凡尔赛，当然不是巴黎。所以他们现在在巴黎市中心，周围都是穿着裤子、拿着长矛、砸碎路标之类东西的人。到处都是不断的因面包引发的骚乱、市场上的争吵以及所有这些。事实上，我们可以从他们写给家里的信件中看出，代表们说，我实际上不再感到安全了。我真心担心我的人身安全。除此之外，从这个时刻（1791年夏天）开始，在他们的脑海深处，有一个关于当秩序彻底崩溃时会发生什么的教训。
France has one really important and lucrative colony, which we haven't talked about at all yet, which is what is now Haiti, or Haiti, which is a place that was then called Saint-Domingue and in August 1790 there had been the first signs of a kind of slave uprising on Saint-Domingue people burning sugarcane fields and so on breaking the machines then at the end of 1790 the black freedmen on that island had launched an uprising at the end of 1791, there will be a mass slave rebellion, a sort of overnight rebellion that will plunge the entire colony into civil war. An extraordinary, extraordinary story. So Dominic, you said most of the deputies in Paris is about order falling apart, but not for all of them. No, abolitionists. There are people who are very enthusiastic about
法国有一个非常重要且利润丰厚的殖民地，我们至今尚未讨论过，这就是现在的海地（Haiti），当时被称为圣多明各（Saint-Domingue）。1790年8月，圣多明各出现了某种奴隶起义的最初迹象，人们焚烧甘蔗田等等，砸毁机器。然后在1790年底，该岛上的黑人自由民发动了一场起义。到1791年底，将发生大规模的奴隶叛乱，这是一种一夜之间的叛乱，将把整个殖民地卷入内战。一个非凡的、非凡的故事。多米尼克，你说巴黎的大多数代表都在谈论秩序崩溃，但并非对所有人都是如此。不，废奴主义者。有些人对此非常热情，
this because one person's order falling apart is obviously another person's declaration of liberty and freedom. Yeah, exactly. That's certainly how the slaves feel about it, obviously. But there are people in Paris who feel this is perfectly in tune with the revolution. The revolution has proclaimed liberty as one of its three founding ideals. There are indeed, yeah. You know, even this is furiously contested. It is, exactly. And you can feel conflicted about it, as some deputies clearly do. Some deputies think,
因为一个人的秩序崩溃显然是另一个人的自由和解放宣言。是的，完全正确。奴隶们显然就是这么认为的。但巴黎有些人觉得这与大革命完全契合。大革命已将自由宣告为其三大基本理想之一。确实如此，是的。你知道，甚至这一点也受到了激烈的争执。是的，完全正确。你可以对此感到矛盾，正如一些代表显然表现出的那样。一些代表认为，
well, I believe in the rights of man. And actually, you know, my sympathies probably do lie with the slaves on Saint-Domingue. But at the same time, they're getting letters from kind of merchants on the Western Atlantic seaboard of France saying, well, our town's entire economy depends upon this. You've got to intervene militarily immediately.
嗯，我信仰人权。实际上，你知道，我的同情心可能确实在于圣多明各的奴隶。但与此同时，他们收到了来自法国西大西洋沿岸商人的信件，上面写着，我们的城镇的整个经济都依赖于此。你们必须立即进行军事干预。
And also we said that one of the principles upheld in the Declaration of the Rights of Man is the right of property. Yeah. And if a slave is at property, then that's in confliction with upholding the ideal of liberty. So there's much to be resolved. So there were all these tensions. And even before the flight to Varennes,
而且我们还说过，《人权宣言》中维护的原则之一就是财产权。是的。如果奴隶是财产，那就与维护自由的理想相冲突。所以还有很多问题需要解决。所以存在着所有这些紧张局势。甚至在逃往瓦雷讷之前，
there had been some people who had looked at all this and said, okay, this has now gone too far. The revolution must now be brought to a swift conclusion and order and kind of normality restored to France. And their champion, and a person who's probably a bit forgotten now in accounts of the revolution, because he's not quite as colourful and charismatic as some of the other characters. But the man who's really the revolution's big star in the summer of 1791
就已经有一些人看着这一切说，好吧，这已经太过分了。大革命现在必须迅速结束，法国的秩序和某种正常状态必须恢复。他们的倡导者——在对大革命的记述中现在可能有点被遗忘的人，因为他不如其他一些角色那么丰富多彩和具有领袖魅力——但是那个在1791年夏天真正成为大革命大明星的人，
is a very young man called Antoine Barnave. So Barnave came from Grenoble. People who listened to the first season will remember the French Revolution began in Grenoble. And he's a Protestant, isn't he, as well? And he's a Protestant, yeah. And the Protestants do, you know, as the Luther and Calvin reference at the beginning, they do play a kind of oversized part in the kind of imagination of the revolution. He's a classic revolutionary.
是一个名叫安托万·巴纳夫（Antoine Barnave）的年轻人。所以巴纳夫来自格勒诺布尔（Grenoble）。听过第一季的人会记得，法国大革命始于格勒诺布尔。而且他也是个新教徒，对吧？他是一个新教徒，是的。正如开头提到的路德和加尔文一样，新教徒确实在大革命的想象中扮演了过分重要的角色。他是一个典型的革命者。
He's a lawyer's son. He's a lawyer himself. He's very young. He's only 27 when the Bastille falls. He had become one of the great stars of the National Assembly. He was a founder member of the Jacobin Club. He drew up its first rule book. And he has a little faction allied to him, people who I suppose you might call,
他是一个律师的儿子。他自己就是个律师。他很年轻。巴士底狱陷落时他才27岁。他已成为国民议会的巨星之一。他是雅各宾俱乐部的创始成员。他起草了第一本规则手册。他有一个与他结盟的小派系，我猜你可以称他们为——
for want of a better word, liberals. So there's a couple of noblemen called Lameth. There is a magistrate in Paris called Duport. And they think, by the summer of 1791, they think, and lots of people think, these are the people, this is the faction that are going to run the revolution. And their attitude is this. They say, look, of people think, these are the people, this is the faction that are going to run the revolution. And their attitude is this. They say, look, the disorder has gone way out of control. We need to end all this. We need to end all the chaos, the polemics from the clubs and from the radical press.
原谅我词穷——自由派。所以有几个贵族叫拉梅特（Lameth）。巴黎有一个地方法官叫迪波尔（Duport）。到1791年夏天，他们认为，许多人也认为，这些人、这个派系将掌控大革命。他们的态度是这样的。他们说，看，
We need to restore order in the army. The way we can fix the economy is by further liberalization. We need to scrap all the antiquated regulations and things. We need to have a proper laissez-faire economy. So scrap price controls, have a free market. Let the free market work its magic. They reminded me when I was reading about this of the people who were around Boris Yeltsin in the 1990s.
混乱已经失控了。我们需要结束这一切。我们需要结束所有的混乱，结束来自俱乐部和激进媒体的论战。我们需要恢复军队的秩序。我们修复经济的方法是通过进一步的自由化。我们需要废除所有陈旧的规章制度之类。我们需要建立一个真正的自由放任经济。所以废除价格管制，实行自由市场。让自由市场发挥其魔力。当我读到关于这方面的内容时，他们让我想起了1990年代鲍里斯·叶利钦身边的人。
Well, that worked out well, didn't it? In Russia, yeah, it worked out equally well. So they're kind of liberal know liberal reformers think tank people who basically have figured out how they think they'll fix france it'll be short-term pain but in the long run they think it will all pay off but also dominic i'm guessing further example which i know is the revolution themselves aware of is england after the civil war yeah and that sense also then of radical thoughts opinions incredible liberty of expression and the sense that there does need to be control at the center and there needs to be if not a monarch then a monarchical figure but i'm guessing that
嗯，那结果可不怎么样，不是吗？在俄罗斯，是的，结果同样不妙。所以他们是那种自由派、精通改革的智库人士，他们基本上已经弄清楚了他们认为如何能修复法国。这将是短期的痛苦，但从长远来看，他们认为这一切都会得到回报。但同时，多米尼克，我猜还有一个例子，我知道大革命的人自己也意识到，那就是内战后的英国。是的，那种激进的思想、观点、不可思议的言论自由，以及感觉到中心确实需要控制，如果没有一个君主，也需要有一个君主制的形象。但我猜
bernard i mean i well i know bernard is, we already have a king. So let's try and work with him. Or more specifically, let's try and work with the queen. Yeah. You could see them as wigs, actually, in some ways, Tom. You could see them as a little bit wiggish. They're all about free trade. They're all about a kind of liberal oligarchy. Sensible people.
巴纳夫，我的意思是——我了解巴纳夫——我们已经有了一个国王。所以让我们试着和他合作。或者更具体地说，让我们试着和王后合作。汤姆，在某些方面，你确实可以把他们看作辉格党人。你也可以把他们看作有点辉格党倾向。他们全力支持自由贸易。他们全力支持某种自由寡妇政治（译者注：原文为oligarchy，指寡头政治）。理智的人。
With a neutered monarchy. Yes, exactly. So they've already, by the way, passed a law called the Le Chapelier Law to clamp down on strikes and workers. That has made them quite unpopular on the streets. But as you rightly say, they think they can use Louis and Marie Antoinette. Now, Barnard had been one of the three deputies who had gone to get them back from Varennes. And he had sat, people will remember who listened to the final episode of the last series,
带着一个被阉割的君主。是的，完全正确。顺便说一句，他们已经通过了一项名为“勒夏普利埃法”（Le Chapelier Law）的法律，以镇压罢工和工人。这使他们在街头非常不受欢迎。但正如你所说的那样，他们认为他们可以利用路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特。现在，巴纳夫是去瓦雷讷把他们接回来的三名代表之一。正如听过上一季最后一集的听众会记得的，他曾坐在
he had been there sitting in the coach with Marie Antoinette on the way back. And he had thought to himself, ah, this is brilliant. And with the Queen, she's very charming. I think we can do business together. And this is so crucial about how both Benav and indeed Marie Antoinette come to be seen. Because the idea of Marie Antoinette as a
回程的马车里，和玛丽·安托瓦内特坐在一起。他当时心里想，啊，这太棒了。至于王后，她非常迷人。我想我们可以一起做生意。关于巴纳夫和玛丽·安托瓦内特是如何被看待的，这一点至关重要。因为玛丽·安托瓦内特被视为一个
manipulative whore who only has to meet a man to work her wiles on him and seduce him and corrupt him, it's like Cleopatra with Antony. It totally is. And from this point on, the moment Benav is back, even while he seems the cock of the roost, the pornographers, the satirists are getting to work and are portraying him as a kind of a dupe of the Queen, like Louis, that he is the victim of this vampire-ess. But you know what, Tom? As with what we're saying about the paranormal and the conspiracies, they're not entirely wrong.
操纵人心的婊子，只要见一个男人就能对施展媚惑、勾引并腐蚀他，就像安东尼的克利奥帕特拉一样。完全是这样。从这一刻起，巴纳夫回来的那一刻，尽管他似乎是当之无愧的头号人物，但色情作家、讽刺作家们却开始行动了，把他描绘成王后的一个傀儡，就像路易一样，认为他是这个吸血鬼女皇的受害者。但你知道吗，汤姆？就像我们对超自然现象和阴谋的看法一样，他们并非完全错误。
No, they're not. But it's not a sexual seduction, is it? No, it's not. It's a political seduction. It's a political seduction. He got back and he thought, I can do business with the Queen. We understand each other.
不，他们没有。但这并不是一种性诱惑，对吧？不，不是的。这是一场政治诱惑。这是一场政治诱惑。他回来后心想，我可以和王后做生意。我们彼此理解。
I understand now where she's coming from, her anxiety for her family. She understands that I'm the man. You know, she respects me. And they start exchanging coded letters. And basically, Barnard says, let's do a deal. I will make sure the National Assembly go easy on you you must give up all thoughts of escape you must commit yourselves to making the new constitution
我现在理解她的出发点了，她对家人的焦虑。她理解我是那个人。你知道，她尊重我。他们开始交换密信。基本上，巴纳夫说，我们做个交易吧。我保证国民议会对你们从轻发落，你们必须放弃所有逃跑的想法，你们必须致力于让新宪法
work now in return I will make sure that the new constitution has a really good solid role for the monarchy that you'll still have powers you'll still have your self-respect on all of that kind of thing and actually to begin with he's pretty much as good as his word. When they wake up, the morning after those gates have clanged shut at the Tuileries Palace, they might be expecting they'll face a show trial, they'll face really aggressive interrogation. There's none of that. Now, they are under house arrest. They can't go out of the Tuileries. They can't even close the door of their rooms. They're constantly supervised, understandably, because they'll try to run away again. But thanks to Barnard and his pals, the National Assembly treat them with great tolerance.
运转起来。作为回报，我将确保新宪法为君主制扮演一个非常好的、坚实的角色，你们仍然拥有权力，你们仍然拥有自尊心以及所有类似的事情。事实上，一开始他基本上说到做到。当他们在杜伊勒利宫那些大门砰然关闭的第二天早晨醒来时，他们可能会预料到自己会面临一场作秀审判，面临非常咄咄逼人的讯问。根本没有那回事。现在，他们被软禁了。他们不能离开杜伊勒利宫。他们甚至不能关上房间的门。他们受到持续的监督，这是可以理解的，因为他们会再次试图逃跑。但多亏了巴纳夫和他的伙伴们，国民议会以极大的宽容对待他们。
They send a committee to interview them, but they give them 24 hours to get their story straight. And when Marion, Toinette and Louis say, well, listen, we were just frightened. We were running away to where we thought we'd be safe, but we absolutely would never have raised an army to march on Paris. The very idea of it. And the idea that we would be in touch with foreign powers, never.
他们派了一个委员会来采访他们，但他们给了他们24小时来统一口径。当玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易说，嗯，听着，我们只是害怕。我们逃跑是为了去我们以为安全的地方，但我们绝对永远不会集结军队向巴黎进军。这想法太荒谬了。而且我们与外国势力有联系的想法，绝无可能。
I mean, those are outright brazen lies. We were possibly quite sympathetic to Louis-Améry Trenet in our previous episode, but they are lying about this. They were talking to the Austrians and they were thinking about marching on Paris. There are a lot of lies that the king is telling. I mean, he clearly feels that he's obedient to a higher calling. Yeah, he does. That would be his justification, wouldn't it? But he's still, I mean, he's absolutely fibber.
我的意思是，那是公然的厚颜无耻的谎言。我们在上一集中可能对路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特相当同情，但他们在撒谎。他们当时正在与奥地利人交谈，并且考虑过向巴黎进军。国王在撒很多谎。我的意思是，他清楚地感觉到自己是在顺从一个更高的召唤。是的，他是。那是他的借口，对吧？但他仍然——我的意思是，他绝对是个骗子。
He is a fibber. So thanks to Barnard, the National Assembly decides that they will reinstate Louis, as long as he promises to obey the constitution. And when a few people in the assembly say, I don't know about this, he has behaved very badly. Barnard gives a brilliant speech and he says, the next step that the revolution takes would be a very dangerous one. It would undoubtedly be an attack on your, our property. It is time to conclude the revolution. It needs to stop. The nation is free and all the French are equals. So let's, you know, no more. Except they're not, are they? No, of course not. Because they still have a monarchy. I mean, that's the whole point. But from their point of view, their property owners, remember,
他是个骗子。所以多亏了巴纳夫，国民议会决定恢复路易的职务，只要他答应遵守宪法。当议会中的少数人说，我不知道这是否可行，他表现得很糟糕时。巴纳夫发表了一场精彩的演讲，他说，大革命采取的下一步将是非常危险的一步。这无疑将是对你们的、我们的财产的攻击。是时候结束大革命了。它需要停止。国家是自由的，所有的法国人都是平等的。所以让我们，你知道的，别再这样了。等等，他们并非如此，不是吗？不，当然不是。因为他们仍然有君主制。我的意思是，这就是重点。但从他们的角度来看，他们是财产所有者，记住，
a lot of these deputies, they're like, you know what? He's probably right probably right because i actually have always been a monarchist i do have a fair bit of property i have my country house i have you know my parents have a whatever whatever yeah he's right you know let's calm things down so the national assembly decides on the 15th of july so the day after the thing that you began with tom the bastille day the day after that the assembly votes fine louis swear an oath when we finish the constitution we swear an oath and then he's back the thing that you began with, Tom, the Bastille Day. The day after that, the Assembly votes, fine. Louis, swear an oath. When we finish the Constitution, we swear an oath, and then he's back.
这些代表中的许多人都在想，你知道吗？他是对的，可能是对的，因为我实际上一直是个君主主义者，我确实拥有相当多的财产，我有我的乡间别墅，我有——你知道的，我的父母有这样那样的东西——是的，他是对的，你知道的，让我们冷静下来。所以国民议会在7月15日——也就是你开头提到的那个日子，巴士底日的第二天——国民议会投票决定，好吧。路易，宣誓吧。当我们完成宪法时，我们宣誓，然后他就回来了。你开始的那件事，汤姆，巴士底日。那之后的第二天，议会投票决定，好吧。路易，宣誓。当我们完成宪法时，我们宣誓，然后他就回来了。
And of course, all the radicals, so the Cordulier Club, this club on the left bank full of artists and working-class radicals and Desmoulins and Marat and Danton, they go ballistic. On the evening when they hear about this, there are people in there saying, listen, the deputies have been bought and paid for by the court. Barnard and all these people are in bed with Marie Antoinette. This is unbelievable. The king ran away to the frontier to try to get a foreign army to attack us.
当然，所有的激进派，也就是科德利埃俱乐部——这个位于左岸、挤满艺术家和工人阶级激进分子的俱乐部，以及德穆兰、马拉和丹东——都气炸了。当晚听到这个消息时，里面有人说，听着，代表们已经被法院收买和贿赂了。巴纳夫和所有这些人都在和玛丽·安托瓦内特同床异梦。这太难以置信了。国王逃到边境试图找一支外国军队来攻击我们。
And they're just going to let him off when barely even a slap on the wrist. And Dominic, when you look at the pamphlets that are produced in this period, the emphasis on Marie Antoinette as the agent of this is stupefying. She's like the center of a whirlpool of blood. Yeah. Sucking everyone down. And it'll actually get worse. I mean, in the next episode, it will get even worse. So when the news that the assembly has made this decision hits the streets, so this is on the afternoon, the evening of the 15th of July, people go absolutely ballistic. There are people shouting in the cafes. There are brawls. There's a huge protest outside the National Assembly with people
而他们就这样放过他，甚至连象征性的惩罚都没有。多米尼克，当你看到这一时期制作的小册子时，对玛丽·安托瓦内特作为这一事件的代理人的强调简直令人瞠目结舌。她就像血色漩涡的中心。是的。把每个人都吸下去。而且实际上情况会更糟。我的意思是，在下一集中，情况会变得更糟。所以当议会做出这个决定的消息传到街头时——这是在7月15日下午、傍晚——人们彻底气炸了。咖啡馆里有人在大喊大叫。发生了群殴。国民议会外面爆发了大规模抗议，人们
chanting. They invade the theaters and they say that performances should be kind of closed shut down because we should be in mourning for the death of liberty now ominously this is what they had done in 1789 just before the fall of the bastille so people have a real sense yeah something is building something is coming and then on the next the 16th, is a day of extraordinary drama. First of all, at the main club that all the revolutionaries belong to, the Jacobin Club, there is this incredibly bitter session in which a lot of club members are accusing the deputies of treason and of selling out to the monarchy. And Barnav and his friends, the Lameth brothers and this guy, Adrien Dubourg, they say, okay, enough. I'm not standing for this anymore.
他们高喊着。他们冲进剧院，说演出应该被某种程度上关停，因为我们现在应该为自由的死而哀悼。不祥的是，这正是他们在1789年巴士底狱陷落前夕所做的事情，所以人们有一种真实的感觉：是的，有什么东西正在酝酿，有什么事情要发生了。然后在接下来的一天，即16日，是一个充满非同寻常戏剧性的一天。首先，在所有革命者所属的主要俱乐部——雅各宾俱乐部，有一场极其激进痛苦的会议，许多俱乐部成员指责议员叛国，并出卖给君主政体。巴纳夫和他的朋友们，拉梅特兄弟以及这家伙阿蒂安·迪布尔格，他们说，够了。我再也不忍受这个了。
This club has served its purpose. You know, it's time for us to go. And Barnard and co say to all the other deputies, we're out of here. We're not going to stay and be insulted like this. And they all storm out of the Jacobin. Literally, they go across the street to another abandoned monastery. I love the fact that all of these factions are named after monasteries. So this was a Cistercian group called the Foyens.
这个俱乐部已经完成了它的使命。你知道，是我们离开的时候了。巴纳夫等人对所有其他议员说，我们离开这里。我们不会留下来遭受这样的侮辱。他们气势汹汹地冲出了雅各宾俱乐部。字面意思，他们穿过街道去了另一个废弃的修道院。我喜欢这些派系都以修道院命名的事实。所以这是一个叫做福扬派的熙笃会群体。
Of course it was. And they set up a new club called the Society of the Friends of the Constitution, and they are called, obviously, the Foyens Club after these monks. And only six deputies stay behind at the Jacobin Club. And is there a particularly prominent member of these six deputies? There is a man who is going to become more and more prominent as the story goes on,
当然是这样。他们建立了一个名为“宪法之友协会”的新俱乐部，根据这些僧侣，他们显然被称为福扬俱乐部。只有六名议员留在了雅各宾俱乐部。这六名议员中是否有特别突出的成员？有一个人，随着故事的发展，他将变得越来越突出，
and his name is Maximilien Robespierre. So he stays behind at the Jacobin while all the others have gone. Meanwhile, at the club on the left bank, the Cordillier Club, the people there say, right, big rally. Let's take this to the streets. Tomorrow is a Sunday. Perfect. People aren't at work. We'll get everybody to gather. They'll gather at the ruins of the Bastille. And then we'll have a huge march across town. And we'll go to the stadium, to the Champ de Mars stadium, where the altar to the fatherland is,
他的名字叫马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。因此，当所有其他人离开时，他留在了雅各宾派。与此同时，在左岸的科德利埃俱乐部，那里的人说，好吧，来一场大游行。让我们走上街头。明天是星期天。完美。人们不上班。我们将让每个人聚集起来。他们将聚集在巴士底狱的废墟上。然后我们将穿过全城进行一场宏大的游行。我们将前往战神广场体育场，那里有祖国祭坛，
when there's a lot of stuff still hanging around from Bastille Day. And there we will sign this huge petition. It'll be the biggest such thing in history. The petition says, Louis abdicated when he ran after Varennes. France must be a republic. This will be the turning point. And actually, the one person who says, hold on, is Robespierre. Robespierre says, I'm not sure about this. A big rally and all that kind of thing, that will give the Foyen a pretext for a crackdown. We don't really want that. We don't want to give them any semblance of an excuse. I think he comes across from all of these narratives, today's
当时巴士底狱日还留下了很多东西。在那里，我们将签署这份巨大的请愿书。这将是历史上规模最大的一次。请愿书说，路易在追赶瓦雷纳时退位了。法国必须成为一个共和国。这将是一个转折点。事实上，唯一一个说“等等”的人是罗伯斯庇尔。罗伯斯庇尔说，我对这件事不太确定。大规模游行诸如此类的事情，会给福扬派提供镇压的借口。我们其实并不希望那样。我们不想给他们任何借口的外表。我觉得从所有这些叙述中，今天
episode, the next episode we're going to do and so on. He's a very, very shrewd and impressive political operator. The thing is he is quite smart, isn't he? He really is. He's tactically cunning, Robespierre. He can see what's coming. But of course,, isn't he? He really is. He's tactically cunning, Robespierre. He can see what's coming. But of course, people don't recognize that at the time. They say, no, no, no, no, no. It'll be brilliant. We'll have this huge march.
这一集，我们接下来要做的一集等等。他是一个非常、非常精明且令人印象深刻的政治运作人员。问题是他确实很聪明，不是吗？他真的是。他在战术上很狡猾，罗伯斯庇尔。他能看出接下来会发生什么。但当然，不是吗？他真的是。他在战术上很狡猾，罗伯斯庇尔。他能看出接下来会发生什么。但当然，当时人们并没有认出这一点。他们说，不，不，不，不，不。这会很棒的。我们将进行这场巨大的游行。
We'll have a great rally, all of that kind of thing. What could go wrong? Yeah, what can go wrong? They break up that evening, the 16th. They say, you know, there will be so many of us, the deputies will have to give in. Louis will fall, and France can walk into the new dawn of a Republican tomorrow. But, Tom, it will not work out like that.
我们将举办一次盛大的集会，诸如此类的事情。能出什么差错？是的，能出什么差错？16日那天傍晚，他们解散了。他们说，你知道，会有那么多的人，议员们将不得不屈服。路易将倒台，法国可以步入共和主义明天的崭新黎明。但是，汤姆，事情不会那样发展的。
Well, we'll find out how it does work in the second half. So please join us then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
好吧，我们将在下半场找出事情是如何运作的。所以请加入我们。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And for those of you who are watching this on YouTube, you'll be delighted to see that I took the opportunity of the break to put a blanket up to stop the sun blinding my eyes and turning me very, very pale. So Dominic, high drama in Paris. It's the morning of Sunday, the 17th of July. Weather is clear.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史即全部》。对于那些在YouTube上观看的人，你会很高兴地看到，我利用休息的机会挂了一块毯子，以防止阳光刺痛我的眼睛并把我晒得非常非常苍白。多米尼克，巴黎正上演着高度戏剧性的一幕。那是7月17日星期天的早晨。天气晴朗。
It's going to be hot. It's going to be sunny. What happens? So as the dawn breaks everywhere across Paris, there are the members of these kind of radical groups called the fraternal societies and clubs and so on streaming to the agreed meeting point, which is the Place de la Bastille.
天气会很热。会很晴朗。发生了什么？因此，当黎明打破巴黎各处的寂寞时，被称为兄弟会和俱乐部等各类激进团体的成员涌向了约定的集合点，即巴士底狱广场。
But when they get there, they find that the entrances to the square are blocked by guards, by members of the National Guard. What's going on? Well, what is going on is the city authorities have been busy overnight. Now, the city authorities, the two people who run Paris, they're both men of 1789. So they're what you would call kind of liberal reformers. One of them is the mayor, who is a guy called Jean-Sylvain Bailly. He's an astronomer, isn't he? He loves staring at the sky. And he's a fan of the tax evader, Benjamin Franklin. So he's a great pal of the Americans. And the other fellow is also tainted by his association with North America. And that's the Marquis de Lafayette, the guy who runs the National Guard. The man described by the official dictionary of the French Revolution
但当他们到达那里时，他们发现广场的入口被卫兵、国民自卫队的成员封锁了。怎么回事？嗯，怎么回事是城市当局连夜忙碌。现在，城市当局，管理巴黎的这两个人，都是1789年的人。所以他们是你所称的自由派改革者。其中一人是市长，一个叫让-西尔万·巴伊的家伙。他是个天文学家，对吧？他喜欢凝视天空。他是逃税者本杰明·富兰克林的粉丝。所以他是美国人的好朋友。另一个家伙也因其与北美的联系而受到玷污。那就是拉斐特侯爵，管理国民自卫队的人。法国大革命官方辞典中描述的那个人
as an empty-headed political dwarf. He's back on the scene. Well, old Dominic, you could say he's tainted by his association with America. You could say burnished by his glorious feats in defence of liberty. And he's actually, I think, played a very, very difficult hand pretty well and is a rather admirable figure. Well, people who were persuaded by your defence of Lafayette in season one very difficult hand pretty well and is a rather admirable figure. Well, people who were persuaded by your defense of Lafayette in season one will be disappointed to hear that in season two of the French Revolution, Lafayette's career collapses in absolute shame
是一个头脑空洞的政治侏儒。他又回到了现场。老多米尼克，你可以说他因与美国的联系而受玷污。你也可以说，由于他在保卫自由方面的光荣壮举而焕发光彩。实际上，我认为他把一副非常非常困难的牌打得相当不错，是一个相当令人钦佩的人物。好吧，那些在第一季中被你对拉斐特的辩护说服的人，牌打得非常困难却相当不错，是一个相当令人佩服的人物。好吧，那些在法国大革命第二季中被你对拉斐特的辩护说服的人，听到拉斐特的职业生涯在绝对的耻辱中崩溃，会感到失望
and ignominy. Yeah, but he's not alone, is he? He's running up a down escalator and he does survive. He will live to see another revolution. All of these guys we're talking about, they're all going to end up dead. They are. I mean, this is the extraordinary thing. Whenever I do these episodes, I always think, let's look at the names at the end. And I look through the names like, yeah, he was dead six months later. He's guillotined, whatever, whatever. So Lafayette has been moving rightwards all this time. Or you could say everyone else has been moving leftwards.
和耻辱。是的，但他并不孤单，对吧？他正在逆行下行的自动扶梯，但他确实活了下来。他将活着看到另一场革命。我们谈论的所有这些家伙，他们最终都会死掉。他们会的。我的意思是，这是一件非凡的事情。每当我做这些节目时，我总是想，让我们看看最后的名单。我浏览着那些名字，心想：是的，他六个月后就死了。他被送上断头台，诸如此类。所以拉斐特这段时间一直在向右移动。或者你可以说其他所有人都在向左移动。
I suppose you could. Yes, you could, of course. You could say that. Because he has been using the National Guard to implement the attempt to clamp down on strikes and worker unrest. So he's actually, he's gone from being the darling of the streets to being drawn further and further into conflict with the streets. Well, it's his job to keep order in Paris.
我想你可以。是的，你可以，当然。你可以这么说。因为他一直在利用国民自卫队来实施镇压罢工和工人骚乱的尝试。所以他实际上，他已经从街头的宠儿变成了越来越深地卷入与街头的冲突中。好吧，他的工作是维持巴黎的秩序。
Tom, you are so Team Lafayette. What have they got on you, the Lafayette family? I'm just trying to see the world through his eyes and having some sympathy. I'm not criticising him, but of all the people that you know, I'm not talking about Justin's podcast, but life generally, can you think of anybody who's generally more in favour of using troops to break up street disorder? I'm usually all over that. Churchill?
汤姆，你太支持拉斐特了。拉斐特家族对你有什么把柄？我只是试着通过他的眼光来看待世界，并抱有一些同情。我不是在批评他，但在你认识的所有人中，我不是指贾斯汀的播客，而是泛指生活，你能想到谁更普遍地赞成使用军队来镇压街头骚乱吗？我通常对此全盘接受。丘吉尔？
Yeah, but you don't know Churchill. I mean, you know of him. Oh, I see. Yeah, right. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, but the reason you despise Lafayette is he's not very good at it. Yes, exactly.
是的，但你并不认识丘吉尔。我的意思是，你知道他。噢，我明白了。是的，对。是的。好吧。是的，但你鄙视拉斐特的原因是他不太擅长这个。是的，没毛病。
I like competence. I like competence. But he's torn between his conscience and his duty. I like competence and the regular payment of taxes. That's what I believe in. Right. So the demonstrators have been blocked off by lafayette's troops so they say well we're not going to do the big rally we'll just go by sideways to the
我喜欢能力。我喜欢能力。但他内心在良心与职责之间痛苦挣扎。我喜欢能力和按时纳税。这就是我所相信的。好吧。因此，示威者被拉斐特的军队挡住了，所以他们说，好吧，我们不搞大型集会了，我们从旁边绕到
chandeliers which actually they do and when they see the national guard are there some of them say okay we're in for trouble and so they have like rocks in their pockets some of them even i think have pistols they know that there is danger today in this sunday So a midday, the stadium is starting to fill up. And as it's filling up, people notice this sort of shuffling and moving going on under the platform where the altar is. And they go to investigate. Two very improbable figures. Yeah. So they find that hiding under the platform beneath the altar are a young man who makes wigs and an older man who has a wooden leg and with them they have like a picnic hamper with kind of a lunch you know a nice spread and they have a load of carpenter's tools what historians think is that these two men hiding under the platform had a plan to use the
沙龙，实际上他们也确实这么做了，当他们看到国民自卫队在那里时，他们中的一些人说，好吧，我们有麻烦了，所以他们的口袋里有石头，我甚至认为有些人有手枪。他们知道今天这个星期天有危险。因此，在中午时分，体育场开始填满人。随着它被填满，人们注意到平台下、祭坛下方发生的那种拖着脚步和移动的现象。他们去调查。两个极不可能的人物。是的。因此，他们发现躲在祭坛下方平台底下的有一个做假发的年轻人和一个装有木腿的老年人，他们随身带着一个野餐篮，里面有午餐，你知道的，丰盛的食物，他们还带着一堆木匠工具，历史学家认为这两个藏在平台底下的人有一个计划，那就是利用这些
tools to drill holes in the platform so they could as women were crossing the platform to sign the petition, they would look up their skirts. These upskirting. Upskirters, exactly. But the rumor goes around that they had a bomb, that they're terrorists, that they're kind of royalist terrorists or something. And they are dragged away by a group of laundry men who literally, they string them up on a lamppost, they hang them from a lampp post. And then, Tom, they cut their heads off.
工具在平台上钻洞，这样当女人穿过平台签署请愿书时，他们就可以偷看她们的裙底。偷窥裙底的人，正是。但谣言四起，说他们有炸弹，说他们是恐怖分子，是某种保王党恐怖分子之类的。他们被一群洗衣工拖走，字面意思，他们把他们吊在路灯柱上，把他们挂在路灯柱上。然后，汤姆，他们砍掉了他们的头。
I mean, that escalated very quickly. I mean, it's a good way to celebrate Bastille Day, isn't it? To string someone up and then chop their heads off and parade the head on a spike. It's true to the spirit of Bastille Day, I suppose you could say. But it's quite, I mean, I don't approve of the wig maker and the wooden leg man's behavior, but it's a tough penalty, I think. Anyway, news of this travels across paris there's been terrorists or something or upskirters lurking around at the stadium and they've had their heads cut off it reaches city hall the hotel de ville and by the astronomer says oh my god this shows that this is totally out of control he says and this is a sign of the rhetoric that's
我的意思是，那升级得太快了。我的意思是，这是庆祝巴士底日的好方法，不是吗？把某人吊死，然后砍掉他们的头，把头挂在长矛上游街。这符合巴士底日的精神，我想你可以这么说。但这相当，我的意思是，我不赞成假发匠和木腿男的行为，但这是一个严厉的惩罚，我认为。无论如何，这方面的消息传遍了巴黎，体育场周围潜伏着恐怖分子或偷窥裙底的人，他们的头被砍掉了，消息传到了市政厅，大楼里的天文学家说，哦，天哪，这表明这完全失控了，他说，这是一个迹象，表明这种修辞
going to be used throughout the revolution. He says to the city council, this whole rally is a foreign plot, a conspiracy against the constitution and the nation financed by foreigners who are attempting to divide us. He flies the red flag, which is the flag of martial law. He declares martial law and he sets off with a small group of troops towards the Champ de Mars. When he gets to the stadium, the Marquis de Lafayette is there with hundreds of national guardsmen. And they're like, right, let's go and break this thing up. Now, inside the stadium, there are perhaps 50 to 60,000 people. And a lot of those are radical supporters, but
将在整个革命过程中被使用。他对市议会说，这场集会是一个外国阴谋，是一场针对宪法和国家的阴谋，由试图分裂我们的外国人资 FINANCE。他升起了红旗，这是戒严令的旗帜。他宣布戒严，并带着一小队军队前往战神广场。当他到达体育场时，拉斐特侯爵和数百名国民自卫队员在那里。他们说，好，让我们去把这事驱散。现在，在体育场内，可能聚集了5万到6万人。其中许多人是激进支持者，但
of course, a lot of those are just people. It's a Sunday. It's a very nice day. So it's fun. It's a fun thing to do. Go out with your family, have a stroll, see what's going on. It's a day out. And lots of people would have gone to the Champs-Élysées anyway on a warm summer Sunday. So there are tens of thousands of people there. And of them, perhaps 6,000 have already started to sign the petitions.
当然，其中许多人只是普通人。今天是星期天。天气非常好。所以很有趣。这是一件有趣的事。和家人一起出去，散散步，看看发生了什么。这是外出的一天。在温暖的夏天星期天，很多人无论如何都会去香榭丽舍大街。所以那里有成千上万的人。其中，大约6,000人已经开始签署请愿书。
Lafayette starts to march its men in through the southern embankment of the stadium and people start booing and some of those people start to throw stones at the National Guard. And then, we don't know when, we don't know how exactly, a single shot rings out and it's the classic way that these things start.
拉斐特开始率领手下通过体育场的南堤进入，人们开始发出嘘声，其中一些人开始向国民自卫队投掷石头。然后，我们不知道什么时候，我们不知道具体如何，一声枪响划破长空，这是这些事情开始的经典方式。
No one knows who's fired it, but the guardsmen immediately assume they're being fired upon by the crowd. They kind of drop to their knees and start shooting. And suddenly it's all total chaos and there are more and more shots. There's no one among the National Guards who worry about this because that was an issue when the National Guard go to Versailles to bring the King Queen back a year or so earlier. Is that Lafayette can't be certain that his men will follow him. No, he can't. On this occasion, they do.
没有人知道是谁开的枪，但卫兵立即认为他们遭到了人群的射击。他们跪下并开始射击。突然一切陷入彻底的混乱，越来越多的枪声响起。国民自卫队中没有人为此感到担忧，因为当国民自卫队在一年前左右前往凡尔赛把国王王后带回来时，这是一个问题。那是拉斐特无法确信他的人会跟随他。不，他不能。在这次机会中，他们做到了。
They do. And maybe because they are being stoned by the crowd, I would guess. And there's a sense of camaraderie. I mean, you're absolutely right. It's remarkable in some ways that the National Guard do stay loyal to Lafayette, given, as we'll see in the next few episodes,
他们确实照做了。也许是因为他们被人群用石头袭击了，我猜。有一种同甘共苦的感觉。我的意思是，你完全说得对。在某些方面，国民自卫队对拉斐特保持忠诚是引人注目的，鉴于正如我们将在接下来的几集里看到的那样，
their loyalty cannot be depended upon. But at yes then there is total chaos there are thousands of people screaming and running everywhere another detachment of guardsmen on horseback charges into the stadium starts trampling people running them down troopers are hacking at people with their sabers. Very Peterloo massacre. Yeah but Peterloo massacre with with knobs on because when the firing finally dies down it's a few minutes only, but when the firing dies down, there are dozens of bodies everywhere. And if you look at estimates, they differ wildly. So at the bottom end, it's perhaps 50 people dead and hundreds injured.
他们的忠诚是不可靠的。但在是的，然后是一片彻底的混乱，有成千上万的人在尖叫，四处奔跑。另一支骑兵卫队冲进体育场，开始践踏人群，将他们撞倒，士兵们用军刀砍杀人们。非常像彼得卢屠杀。Yeah，但彼得卢屠杀更带劲，因为当枪声终于平息时，虽然只有几分钟，但当枪声平息时，到处都是几十具尸体。如果你看看估计数字，它们大相径庭。因此，在低端，可能有50人死亡，数百人受伤。
The radicals themselves said that hundreds of people had been killed and thousands injured. I mean, we can't possibly know. But it is a very, very bloody afternoon and a terrible shock to the kind of body politic of Paris. Because this is the first outbreak of mass violence in Paris since the Bastille, right? It is, exactly. And it's the first outbreak of violence where the violence has been perpetrated by the forces of order against a defenseless crowd. I think that's what people find so shocking. But it's also the first example of revolutionaries on revolutionaries.
激进派自己说数百人被杀，数千人受伤。我的意思是，我们绝对不可能知道。但这确实是一个非常、非常血腥的下午，对巴黎的政治共同体来说是一个可怕的打击。因为这是自巴士底狱陷落以来巴黎发生的第一次大规模暴力事件，对吧？是的，确实如此。这是第一次暴力事件是由秩序力量对无防御的人群实施的。我认为这就是人们感到如此震惊的原因。这也是革命者对革命者的第一个例子。
Exactly. Yeah, it is. And the different groups of revolutionaries interpret it very differently. So for Barnard and the Foyon and Lafayette and Bailly the mayor, this is a sign of the danger of disorder. An overdue warning that it is time to put all this to an end and crack down because this is going to become the norm if you don't stop it. For the radicals, it's a sign that Bailly and Lafayette have joined the corrupt conspiracy being run by Marie Antoinette and they hate the people. And actually, big spoiler alert, Bailly is going to end up dead. He's going to end up being sentenced to death. And as a special treat for him, they move the guillotine to the Champs-de-Mars
没错。是的，确实是。不同派别的革命者对此有非常不同的解读。所以对于巴纳夫、福扬派、拉斐特和市长巴伊来说，这是无序危险的标志。这是一个迟来的警告，是时候结束这一切并进行镇压了，因为如果你不阻止它，这将成为常态。对于激进派来说，这是巴伊和拉斐特加入了由玛丽·安托瓦内特经营的腐败阴谋并且他们痛恨人民的标志。事实上，剧透一下，巴伊最终会死。他将被判处死刑。作为对他的特殊款待，他们把断头台搬到了战神广场
so that he can be executed on the very spot where he's accused of kind of carrying out this massacre. So that's a kind of a sign of how bad things are going to get. But actually in the short term, the Champs-Élysées does seem to be a victory for the moderates because the assembly immediately passes a very strict anti-riot decree and makes it retroactive so they can punish offenses carried out before the rally on the Champs-Élysées. So within days, more than 200 people have been imprisoned, some of them just for throwing stones or even shouting slogans. There are dozens of people who are held for weeks in solitary confinement without trial, without even being
以便他可以在他被指控实施这场屠杀的地方被处决。所以这某种程度上表明了事情将会变得多么糟糕。但实际上在短期内，香榭丽舍大街似乎是温和派的胜利，因为议会立即通过了一项非常严厉的反骚乱法令，并使其具有追溯效力，以便他们可以惩罚在香榭丽舍大街集会之前进行的违法行为。因此在几天之内，200多人被关入监狱，其中一些人仅仅因为投掷石头甚至高喊口号。有数十人被单独关押数周，没有审判，甚至没有被
told the charges against them. And it is part of a much more general crackdown in the summer of 1791. But it still strikes me as strange that the general mood of opposition to the monarchy that seems to be manifesting itself, and the fact that the victims of this massacre are being widely mourned, that the Fajars should have had the tools for oppression at their hand, that the Lafayette's men should have followed him. I mean, I never really made that point, but it does seem quite, I suppose it suggests that we perhaps shouldn't assume that the kind of the onward sweep of the revolution is as inevitable as it seems, do you think? I think part of it is that, Tom, you're approaching this knowing what we know, which is we know the revolution is going to continue and it's going to get worse and it's going to become more polarized, more radical, or better, if you like,
告知对他们的指控。这是1791年夏天更普遍镇压的一部分。但它仍然让我觉得奇怪的是，反对君主制的普遍情绪似乎正在显现，而且这场屠杀的受害者正在被广泛哀悼，福扬派手中本应掌握着压迫的工具，拉斐特的士兵本应跟随他。我的意思是，我从来没有真正指出这一点，但这确实看起来很，我想这表明我们也许不应该假设革命的滚滚向前势不可挡，正如它看起来那样不可避免，你觉得呢？我认为部分原因在于，汤姆，你带着我们所知道的知识来接近这一点，那就是我们知道革命将继续下去，并且它会变得更糟，它将变得更加两极分化，更加激进，或者更好，如果你愿意的话，
that kind of thing. They don't know that. And so there are lots of people who think, oh, wow, this has now definitely gone much too far. There are lots of people who do crave stability and they want the return of order. You made the comparison with the English Revolution of the 1640s, 1650s, as then there are a lot of people who are anxious about chaos and anarchy. But Lafayette famously didn't become Cromwell. Well, so there is a definite sense in 1791, in the summer of 1791 actually, that France could be moving towards a more authoritarian regime. So for the first time now, the police are shutting down publishing houses and clubs. I mean, you talk about, could he have become a Cromwell? Lafayette census men across
那种事情。他们并不知道这一点。所以有很多人认为，哦，天哪，这现在绝对走得太远了。有很多人确实渴望稳定，他们希望恢复秩序。你把它与1740年代、1650年代的英国革命进行了比较，当时也有很多人对混乱和无政府状态感到焦虑。但拉斐特并没有像人们熟知的那样成为克伦威尔。好吧，因此在1791年，实际上是在1791年夏天，有一种明确的感觉，即法国可能会走向一个更专制的政权。因此现在警察首次关闭了出版商和俱乐部。我的意思是，你谈到，他能成为克伦威尔吗？拉斐特派人去
the city, they seize copies of radical newspapers like Maraz newspapers, and they destroy them. They even start to reactivate the old royal secret police. And they have people literally spying on conversations in taverns, writing reports, what people are thinking on the streets. The radicals are doing this as well though, aren't they? They're also saying that it's the duty of a patriot. Yes. If he or she suspects a traitor in their midst to denounce that person.
这座城市，他们没收了马拉的报纸等激进报纸的副本，并销毁了它们。他们甚至开始重新激活旧的皇家秘密警察。他们让人们字面意思在酒馆的对话中进行间谍活动，写报告，记录人们在街头思考的事情。不过激进派也在这样做，不是吗？他们还在说这是爱国者的职责。是的。如果他或她怀疑中间有叛徒，就去谴责那个人。
Let's get into that now, actually, because that's such an interesting thing. So there's a brilliant historian called Timothy Tackett. i know you've been reading his stuff as well his books on this period so his book on the flight to varenne and his book on the coming of the terror they are brilliant on this period so 1791 1792 and he says in that what happens now is that a sort of paranoid style of politics becomes completely normalized and institutionalized on every side of the political spectrum understandably because varenne showed that you're right to think there's a conspiracy there absolutely was a conspiracy and that people might be telling lies yes you can't trust anybody if the king could tell a lie then who can you trust yeah and um tackett has this lovely section on a particular trope, a device, which is the idea of the
我们现在就来谈谈这个，实际上，因为这是一件非常有趣的事情。所以有一位出色的历史学家叫蒂莫西·塔凯特。我知道你也在读他的东西，他关于这个时期的书，所以他关于逃往瓦雷纳的书和他关于恐怖来临的书，对于这个时期来说都太棒了：所以1791年1792年，他在书中说，现在发生的事情是，政治的一种偏执风格在政治光谱的各个方面都变得完全正常化和体制化，这是可以理解的，因为瓦雷纳表明你认为存在阴谋是正确的，绝对存在阴谋，人们可能在说谎，是的，你谁也信不过，如果国王都能说谎，那谁还能信呢？是的，而且，塔凯特对一个特定的比喻，
traitor who wears the mask of patriotism. And this was a phrase that had been coined by the radical journalist Mara, the mask of patriotism. And it's so toxic, that's an idea. Because the idea is the more patriotic you appear to be the more keen on the revolution you are the more likely it is that you're actually a traitor who's conspiring against the revolution and you can see why they have this idea a because of there have been conspiracies but b because their sense of I mean, you would know this better than anyone, Tom, their sense of history, which is rooted in the Roman Republic, the unveiling
一个装置，有一个很好的部分，那就是戴着爱国主义面具的叛徒的想法。这是激进记者马拉创造的一个短语，爱国主义的面具。这个想法太具毒性了。因为这个想法是，你表现得越爱国，你对革命越热心，你实际上是一个密谋反对革命的叛徒的可能性就越大，你可以理解为什么他们有这个想法，a是因为曾经存在阴谋，但b是因为他们的历史感，我的意思是，没有人比你更清楚这一点，汤姆，他们的历史感植根于罗马共和国，揭露阴谋诡计，西塞罗对卡蒂利纳阴谋的揭露，他们都在学校里学过。这对于他们如何看待世界是如此核心，以至于，你知道，共和美德不断面临被险恶的、
of plots and conspiracies, the Catiline conspiracy by Cicero, they've all studied it at school. And it's so central to how they view the world that, you know, Republican virtue is constantly in danger of being undermined by sinister, you know, Machiavellian, by liars like the king or like the Foyon or like Mirabeau before him or like Lafayette and all of this kind of stuff. And that the more loudly somebody proclaims his patriotism, the more likely he is to be a traitor and there is no greater service than to expose him to denounce him so in um hillary mantel's novel a place of greater safety the hero is this guy camille demoulin but he had already written he'd published a declaration of the rights of the accuser
你知道的，马基雅维利式的谎言所侵蚀的危险，比如国王，或者福扬派，或者在他之前的米拉波，或者拉斐特和所有这些类型的东西。一个人宣称自己的爱国主义越响亮，他越有可能是叛徒，没有什么比揭露他、谴责他更大的服务了，所以在希拉里·曼特尔的小说《安全之所》中，主人公是这个叫卡米尔·德穆兰的家伙，但他已经写了，他发表了《控告者权利宣言》
and he had said you know to be a good citizen is to accuse and denounce your neighbours. You know, it's incumbent upon you. And the Jacquemin Club actually, from this point onwards, has a rule. All its members must swear an oath to denounce all traitors of the fatherland, even at the risk of our lives and our fortunes. I mean, it's very social media circa 2020, 2021. I mean, it's a feature of left-wing politics from this point on, right? That on the radical end of the left, there's always been a tendency to denounce. Yeah, to call people out.
并且他说，你知道，做一个好公民就是去指控和谴责你的邻居。你知道，这是你义不容辞的责任。从那时起，雅各宾俱乐部实际上有了一条规则。其所有成员必须发誓谴责所有祖国的叛徒，甚至不惜冒着生命和财产的危险。我的意思是，这非常像2020年、2021年前后的社交媒体。我的意思是，这是从这一点开始的左翼政治的一个特征，对吧？在左翼的激进端，一直有一种谴责的倾向。是的，把人揪出来。
To say they're traitors or they're lackeys of capitalism or whatever. And even before the left has really come to power in the revolution, they're already at it. Oh, completely they are. Absolutely they are. So the Jacquemats, you sent a message to all their nationwide kind of sister clubs and they said, we would like you, each club, to send in regular reports on its village or town or area. And at the beginning of the meetings in Paris, the secretary will read out the reports and he'll say, well, here's a report from Brittany. The people there say the such and such guy and this butcher and this whoever, and that this town is full of counter-revolutionaries.
说他们是叛徒或资本主义的走狗之类的。甚至在左翼真正掌权之前，他们就已经开始了。噢，完全是的。绝对是的。所以雅各宾派向全国各地的姊妹俱乐部发出了一个信息，他们说，我们希望你们每个俱乐部都对其村庄、城镇或地区发送定期报告。在巴黎的会议开始时，秘书将宣读报告，并说，好吧，这是来自布列塔尼的报告。那里的人说某某家伙和这个屠夫和这个随便什么人，这个城镇充满了反革命分子。
And this sort of constant now institutionalized search for the enemy within. This is obviously going to be very bad news for all the revolutionaries because they will all end up being consumed by it. Again, I mean, they're not wrong. There are enemies within. There are still nobles present in their chateau across france and of course there are all these priests who have refused to swear an oath of loyalty to the revolution yeah who were seen as being in league with the pope and because of the pope with the catholic authoritarian powers so you're dead right i mean they're not wrong about worrying about this.
这种现在体制化的对内部敌人的搜寻。这显然对所有革命者来说都是坏消息，因为他们最终都会被它吞噬。再说一次，我的意思是，他们并没有错。内部仍然有敌人。法国各地的城堡里仍然有贵族，当然还有所有那些拒绝宣誓效忠革命的神父，是的，他们被视为与教皇勾结，因此由于教皇而与天主教专制强权勾结，所以你是绝对正确的，我的意思是，他们在担心这一点上并没有错。
And there's a group of people we haven't mentioned very much today, the émigrés, the exiles. There are 10,000 of them, and they are literally just across the border in the Rhineland, and they are conspiring against the revolution. And these are the people the king and queen were going off to hang out with. They were indeed. So there are local authorities across France who are now saying,
还有一个我们今天没有怎么提到的群体，流亡者。有1万人，他们字面意思就在莱茵兰的边境对面，他们在密谋反对革命。这些人就是国王和王后要去找的人。他们确实是。所以法国各地的地方当局现在都在说，
okay, the revolution is in danger. France is going to be invaded. We need to read people's posts. We need to go and search the country houses. We need to detain all strangers, travelers, and so on and so forth. And in his book on Varennes, The Flight to Varennes, Tackett has a section about Brittany. And he says, Brittany is a perfect example of where all this is heading. The local authorities there say absolutely clearly, quote, there must be no limit to the measures against the enemy's hatred and fanaticism. And he gives the example of a district called Londono. And in Londono, they organized mass arrests of all nobles and priests who hadn't sworn the oath to the constitution because they said, these guys can't be trusted.
好吧，革命处于危险之中。法国将遭到入侵。我们需要阅读人们的帖子。我们需要去搜查乡村住宅。我们需要拘留所有陌生人、旅行者等等。塔凯特在他关于瓦雷纳的书《逃往瓦雷纳》中，有一个关于布列塔尼的章节。他说，布列塔尼是这一切走向何方的一个完美例子。那里的地方当局非常明确地表示，引述：“对于敌人仇恨和狂热的措施绝不能有限度。”他举了一个叫隆多诺的地区的例子。在隆多诺，他们组织了对所有未宣誓效忠宪法的贵族和神父的大规模逮捕，因为他们说，这些人不可信。
You know, they're a fifth column. And the people of london were challenged about this isn't this a bit extreme they said and i quote it's worth reading because i think it so anticipates what's to follow we had only one choice to seize our enemies before they commit crime and murder we have served both humanity and the constitution in separating out those who would cause trouble and disorder we will not cease pursuing them until the sacred fire which we hold in our breast has purified every corner of the French nation. I mean, that is pretty, you know, you can understand why they're saying it, but at the same time, it's pretty ominous reading, given what we know about what will follow.
你知道，他们是第五纵队。隆多诺的人民对此受到质疑，这难道不是很极端吗？他们说，我引述一下，这很值得一读，因为我认为它太预示了接下来会发生的事情：我们只有一个选择，在我们的敌人犯罪和谋杀之前抓住他们。我们在把那些会引起麻烦和混乱的人分离开来时，既服务了人类也服务于宪法。在我们胸中怀有的神圣之火净化了法兰西民族的每一个角落之前，我们不会停止追捕他们。我的意思是，那是相当，你知道的，你可以理解为什么他们这么说，但与此同时，考虑到我们对接下来会发生的事情的了解，这读起来相当不祥。
But of course, nobody knows in 1791 what will follow. In fact, Barnard thinks, you know, the momentum is still with me. He thinks like Robespierre, the radicals overplayed their hand at the Champ de Mars. And now I have the political space to launch the crackdown I always wanted and to get through the slightly more conservative version of the constitution that I wanted. And so as a result of his deal with marion toinette they come up with a kind of constitutional plan which is when we have elections there will be strict tax and property thresholds for voting and for holding seats and the king will still have a fair bit of power he'll have the right to veto really important he can veto things he doesn't like.
但当然，在1791年没有人知道接下来会发生什么。事实上，巴纳夫认为，你知道，势头仍然在我这边。他像罗伯斯庇尔一样认为，激进派在战神广场过度行事了。现在我有了政治空间来发起我一直想要的镇压，并通过我一直想要的更保守一点的宪法版本。因此，由于他与玛丽·安托瓦内特的交易，他们提出了一个宪法规划，即当我们举行选举时，投票和担任议席将有严格的税收和财产门槛，国王仍然会有相当多的权力，他将有权否决非常重要的东西，他可以否决他不喜欢的东西。
He can choose his own ministers, ambassadors. And Barnabas says to Mariantonet, what more does it take to be king? We're going to give him everything he wants. It'll be fine. Now, he's starting to get now a lot of criticism from the Jacobin Club because people are like,
他可以选择自己的大臣、大使。巴纳夫对玛丽·安托瓦内特说，做国王还需要什么？我们要给他想要的一切。这会没事的。现在，他开始从雅各宾俱乐部那里得到很多批评，因为人们觉得，
he's giving away a lot. And he's clearly very close to the court. And, you know, there's this sort of sense that he's actually overreaching a bit well he is becoming the corrupt minister of the king who is always the object of hatred as mentioned in that song that we quoted at the start of the program and as you say corrupt so on the one hand you have this young man lawyer very fluent very fluent, very articulate, clearly very ambitious, who is, you know, Marianne Twinnett's cat's paw. And on the other hand, you have a man who is literally now being called the incorruptible, and that's Rob Spierre.
他放弃了太多。而且他显然与宫廷非常接近。而且，你知道，有一种感觉，他实际上有点越权了，好吧，他正在成为国王的腐败大臣，国王一直是仇恨的对象，正如我们在节目开始时引用的那首歌中所提到的那样，而且正如你所说的那样腐败，所以一方面，你有一个年轻人，律师，非常流利，非常流利，非常善于表达，显然很有野心，他是玛丽·安托瓦内特的傀儡。另一方面，你有一个现在字面意思被称为“不可腐蚀的人”的男人，那就是罗伯斯庇尔。
And this really is Rob Spierre's moment when his star has been growing but this is the moment when he comes out as the champion of the radical cause so it's worth stopping for a minute and talking about rob spear because rob spear in many ways he's the anti-barnab he's not interested in the trappings of power he's not overtly ambitious for office he seems to care only about the common people and the public good. So Robespierre is from a place called Arras in northeastern France. He's the son of a lawyer. Like you, Tom, he's a very earnest, very intense scholarship boy. He's obsessed with the Roman Republic like you. Like you, he's obsessed with Rousseau.
这确实是罗伯斯庇尔的时刻，他的名声一直在增长，但这是他作为激进事业的拥护者挺身而出的时刻，所以值得花一分钟停下来谈谈罗伯斯庇尔，因为罗伯斯庇尔在许多方面他是反巴纳夫的。他对权力的外表不感兴趣，他对官职没有公开的野心，他似乎只关心普通人和公共利益。所以罗伯斯庇尔来自法国东北部一个叫阿拉斯的地方。他是一个律师的儿子。和你一样，汤姆，他是一个非常认真、非常刻苦的奖学金生。他和你们一样痴迷于罗马共和国。和你一样，他痴迷于卢梭。
Yeah, he's pale, thin. Bony, tall. Vaguely sinister. He's always perfectly turned out like you he uh his hair his his white wig always powdered i think if i wore a wig mine would be perfectly powdered and he has these little kind of glasses kind of steel rimmed glasses some people said rob's beer was brilliant there's a guy called René Levasseur who sat with him when they were in the National Convention. And many years later, he said of Robespierre,
是的，他脸色苍白，消瘦。骨感，高个子。隐隐透着阴险。他总是衣着完美，和你一样，他呃，他的头发，他的白假发总是扑满粉。我想如果我戴假发，我的也会完美地扑满粉。他戴着这种小眼镜，那种钢框眼镜。有人说罗伯斯庇尔很出色。有一个叫勒内·勒瓦瑟的家伙，当他们在国民公会时和他坐在一起。多年后，他对罗伯斯庇尔说，
he was sober, he was chaste, he had few personal needs or ambitions, he had no desire for economic gain. His only ambition was to acquire a reputation as the best and most honest citizen, which I know is what your cricket teammates say about you. But other people who worked with him closely, Tom, told a different story. Did they, Dominic? Yeah.
他很简朴，他很纯洁，他几乎没有什么个人需求或野心，他没有对经济利益的欲望。他唯一的野心是获得最好、最诚实的公民的名声，我知道你的板球队友就是这样评价你的。但其他与他密切合作的人，汤姆，讲述了不同的故事。是吗，多米尼克？是的。
What did they say? Proud, prickly, priggish. Honestly. Cold. My sympathies are all with Robespierre. The thing is, both these things are almost certainly true. I don't think so, Dominic. He is honest and sober and earnest.
他们说了什么？骄傲，易怒，自以为是。老实说。冷淡。我的同情心全在罗伯斯庇尔那边。问题是，这两点几乎肯定都是真的。我不这么认为，多米尼克。他是诚实、简朴和认真的。
Yes. And all of this. But at the same time, clearly, Robespierre is a very cold fish. I mean, he has no private life at all, as far as we can tell. He's totally obsessed with and devoted to politics. Because he's wedded to the good of the people. In a way, no one has a higher appreciation of his own probity and virtue than he does. You know, he's obsessed with his own virtue
是的。所有这一切。但与此同时，很明显，罗伯斯庇尔是一个非常冷漠的人。我的意思是，据我们所知，他根本没有私生活。他完全痴迷于政治并献身于政治。因为他嫁给了人民的福祉。某种程度上，没有人比他自己对自己的正直和美德有更高的评价了。你知道，他痴迷于自己的美德。
he's one of those kind of political monomaniacs we're very familiar with them that this kind of radical politics often throws up somebody who's overpowering moral earnestness actually makes them a very chilly companion but he gives these speeches that at first deputies laugh at they're very long they're very earnest intense full of references to the Romans. Nothing wrong with that, Dominic. Incredibly emotional, though. So his emotionalism, people always talk about Rolf Spheer as chilly, and he's chilly in his personal relations.
他是那种我们非常熟悉的政治偏执狂。这种激进的政治经常产生这样一个人，他压倒性的道德严肃性实际上使他成为了一个非常冷淡的同伴。但他发表的演讲起初遭到议员们的嘲笑，非常长，非常认真，充满对罗马人的引用。这没有什么不对，多米尼克。不过，极其情绪化。所以他的情绪化，人们总是谈论罗伯斯庇尔很冷淡，他在人际关系中确实很冷淡。
But his oratory is not chilly at all. He will be talking about himself as a martyr. He'll be talking about giving his life and shedding tears for the people. He has these long, tortured pauses in his speeches. And all through his letters, his speeches, they're shot through. He's a total conspiracy theorist. So even before the revolution, it's an interesting thing. Historians have looked at the letters of leading revolutionists and they've said, you know, the funny thing about it is that before 1789, most of them weren't paranoid. They'd sometimes talked about conspiracies and stuff, because that was part of the political
但他的演讲风格一点也不冷淡。他会谈论自己是一个烈士。他会谈论为人民献出生命和流泪。他的演讲中有长长的、痛苦的停顿。贯穿他的信件、他的演讲，它们都充满了。他是一个十足的阴谋论者。所以甚至在革命之前，这是一件有趣的事情。历史学家查看了主要革命者的信件，他们说，你知道，有趣的是，在1789年之前，他们大多数人并不偏执。他们有时会谈论阴谋之类的事情，因为那是当时政治
imagination of the day. But they weren't obsessive about it. Robespierre was always obsessive about it. He was somebody who had been on Reddit or something and spent all his time arguing with people on social media and all that, that would have been his personality. Because I think that he has a Manichean sense of the world, doesn't he? That there is, in political terms, good and evil, and he's on the side of good. And the fact that good is being foiled can only be explained by the workings of
想象的一部分。但他们并没有对此痴迷。罗伯斯庇尔一直对此痴迷。他是一个会泡在红迪网或其他地方并花所有时间在社交媒体上与人争论的人，这就是他的性格。因为我认为他对世界有一种摩尼教式的看法，对吧？在政治术语中，有善恶之分，而他站在善良这一边。善良受到阻挠的事实只能用
evil. The fact that there might be economic problems or accidents or incompetence or whatever doesn't quite fit into that. It doesn't quite give it the edge in the drama that clearly Rose Pierre thrills to. I totally agree, Tom. And a lot of people, I think at the beginning, they listen to him and they kind of laugh. And they say, it's all very simplistic with him.
邪恶的运作来解释。可能存在的经济问题、事故、无能或其他什么并不完全符合这一点。它并没有赋予那种罗伯斯庇尔显然为之激动的戏剧性以边缘感。我完全同意，汤姆。很多人，我认为一开始，他们听他说话，然后有点嘲笑他。他们说，他的一切都太简单化了。
There's always an easy answer. It's populism in a way. It's a kind of moralistic populism that a lot of more worldly people you're kind of mirabos or whatever or banal yeah they think it's a bit day class a and a bit kind of down market but as you rightly say the moralism the manichaeanism for some people is intoxicating as early as 17, he got a letter from a young man called Antoine de Saint-Just. And Saint-Just said to him in this letter, I don't know you, but you are a great man. You're the representative of humanity in the Republic. You'd love to get a letter like that, wouldn't you?
总有一个简单的答案。从某种意义上说，这是民粹主义。这是一种道德化的民粹主义，很多更成熟的人——比如你们这些所谓的精英或者无论什么人，或者说世俗的人——认为这有点落伍，有点低端。但正如你所说的那样，这种道德主义、摩尼教对某些人来说是令人陶醉的。早在17岁时，他就收到了一封来自一个叫安托万·德·圣茹斯特的年轻人的信。圣茹斯特在这封信里对他说，我不认识你，但你是一个伟人。你是共和国中人类的代表。你很想收到这样的信吧，对不对？
I get them from Restors History listeners all the time. Robespierre has a towering ego, I think, and a sense of self. But a towering charisma too. I guess if you like that kind of thing. Well, Saint-Just does, and Saint-Just is, as we will see, I mean, he's a very impressive young man, if slightly frightening. Exactly. So for Robespierre, actually, the current political climate is a gift
我经常从“起底历史”听众那里收到这样的信。我认为罗伯斯庇尔有着高傲的自我和强烈的自我意识。但他也有一种极具吸引力的个人魅力。我想如果你喜欢那种类型的话。嗯，圣茹斯特就是这样，正如我们将会看到的，我的意思是，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的年轻人，虽然有点吓人。没错。所以对罗伯斯庇尔来说，当前的政治气候实际上是一份大礼
because every day in the autumn of 1791, he's getting up at the Jacquemin Club. Barnabas and co have walked out of that club, and he gets up and he says, what a load of sellouts they are. Why are people still hungry? Why is the king still hanging around? Why is this constitution much weaker than we thought?
因为在1791年秋天的每一天，他都在雅各宾俱乐部起。巴纳夫等人已经走出了那个俱乐部，而他站起来说，他们真是一群卖国贼。为什么人们还在挨饿？为什么国王还在四处游荡？为什么这部宪法比我们想象的要脆弱得多？
Well, we all know why. It's because they're part of the conspiracy. It's because they've sold out to the Austrian queen and to the forces of international tyranny. Which to a degree, Barnab has done. I mean, there's enough truth in that accusation that you can work with it. Absolutely. So the 3rd of September, the constitution is finally finished and there's a big procession, torch-lit procession, to the Tuileries Palace to deliver it to the king. And Louis says, fine, thank you very much. I'll have a look at it. So what they've given him is
好吧，我们都知道为什么。因为他们是阴谋的一部分。因为他们出卖给了奥地利王后和国际暴政势力。巴纳夫在某种程度上确实这样做了。我的意思是，这个指控中有足够多的真实成分，你可以据此做文章。完全正确。所以9月3日，宪法终于完成了，有一场盛大的游行，火炬游行，前往杜伊勒里宫将其交给国王。路易说，好的，非常感谢。我会看一看的。所以他们交给他的内容是
he will be head of the executive. There'll be a single chamber assembly. Louis can choose his ministers. Louis is head of the army. Louis has a right of veto. Property owners, sort of taxpayers, can vote, but the very poor can't vote. Women can't vote, and slaves can't vote. And so presumably slaves remain property. Slaves remain property, exactly. So we will get onto, in future episodes, some of the people left out of this story, for example, women. But the big question is, it's a compromise. So is it going to be the kind of compromise that basically doesn't really please anybody, but pleases enough people to get through?
他将成为行政首长。将设立一个一院制议会。路易可以挑选他的大臣。路易是军队统帅。路易拥有否决权。财产所有者，也就是纳税人，可以投票，但极贫困的人不能投票。妇女不能投票，奴隶也不能投票。所以大概奴隶依然是财产。奴隶依然是财产，没错。所以我们将在未来的节目中讨论这个故事中被遗漏的一些人，例如妇女。但最大的问题是，这是一个妥协。那么，这会是一种基本上不会真正取悦任何人，但能取悦足够多的人以便通过的妥协吗？
Or is it the kind of compromise that falls between every conceivable stool and pleases nobody at all? And will Louis accept it? The days go by. If Louis doesn't accept that constitution, he is out as king. That is the deal. And his six-year-old son would become king under a regency. So on the 13th of December, he announces his decision.
还是那种两头不讨好、谁也无法取悦的妥协？路易会接受它吗？日子一天天过去。如果路易不接受这部宪法，他就不能再当国王了。这就是交易。而他六岁的儿子将在摄政下成为国王。所以在12月13日，他宣布了他的决定。
He will accept it. And the next day, he goes and swears an oath to maintain it and defend it. And there are great parades and fireworks and bonfires of celebration. There's a huge balloon, patriotic ribbons that flies over the Olympics. Yeah, like the Olympics. And a scientist is in this balloon. He's throwing out copies of the constitution across villages. It's villages all across the Ile de France. For the first time, Louis and Marie-Toinette are allowed out of the palace. They can go to the opera. They can go around the city and whatnot.
他将接受它。第二天，他去宣誓维护和捍卫它。有盛大的游行、烟花和庆祝的篝火。有一个巨大的热气球，上面有飘过奥林匹克的爱国缎带。对，就像奥运会一样。一个科学家在这个气球里。他在法兰西岛的各个村庄上空抛撒宪法的副本。路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特有生以来第一次被允许离开宫殿。他们可以去歌剧院，可以在城市里四处走走等等。
And the deputies are like, it's over. It's done. They meet for the last time on the 30th of September. The new legislative assembly that will succeed them under the new constitution has already been elected. They've agreed that none of them will sit in it, a self-denying audience. So one of their successors comes along and he gives a speech and he says, you have done the most amazing thing. And anyone who wants to succeed you, it will be what Alexander the Great said of Philip II of Macedon.
议员们觉得，结束了。完成了。他们在9月30日召开了最后一次会议。将根据新宪法接替他们的新的立法议会已经选出。他们一致同意他们中没有人会在其中任职，这是一个自我否定的群体。于是他们的一位继任者走来发表了一场演讲，他说，你们做了最了不起的事情。任何想接替你们的人，这都将是亚历山大大帝对马其顿的腓力二世所说的话。
You've left us nothing to conquer because of your amazing achievements. A lot of them are saying they declare the revolution is finished. Brilliant. It's all done and dusted. One of them, a Protestant pastor called Saint-Étienne, he actually has already started writing a kind of semi-official history of the revolution. Brilliant.
由于你们了不起的成就，你们没有给我们留下任何需要征服的东西。他们中的很多人说他们宣布革命已经结束。太棒了。一切都尘埃落定。其中一个人，一个名叫圣艾蒂安的清教徒牧师，其实已经开始撰写一部半官方性质的革命史。太棒了。
Yeah, it's finished. But the thing is, it clearly hasn't finished. And there are two shadows, Tom, of what is coming. So the first thing is that the last sort of full day of the assembly's existence, so the day before they broke up, one of Bonneve's allies, this guy Le Chapelier, had tried to push through a law. He'd said, we don't need all the clubs anymore because it's done. The revolution is over. Now that the revolution is over and the constitution has been decided, order and public peace should prevail. We don't need this ranting and raving in the clubs. And at that, one of these other deputies gets up to interrupt him and it's Rob Spierre. And Rob Spierre says, and I quote, for my part, I can see that the new constitution still has enemies within and without. I can see conspiracy and treachery sounding the alarm as they sow unrest and discord, and the leaders of opposing factions fighting less for the cause of the revolution
是的，结束了。但问题是，它显然还没有结束。汤姆，有两个阴影预示着即将到来的一切。首先是，在议会存在的最后一个完整日，也就是他们解散的前一天，巴纳夫的一个盟友，这个叫勒沙普利耶的家伙，曾试图强行通过一项法律。他说，我们不再需要所有的俱乐部了，因为事情已经完成了。革命结束了。既然革命已经结束，宪法已经决定，秩序和平静应该占上风。我们不需要在俱乐部里大喊大叫。就在这时，另一位议员站起来打断了他，他就是罗伯斯庇尔。罗伯斯庇尔说，我引述一下，就我而言，我可以看到新宪法在内外部依然有敌人。我看到阴谋和背叛在敲响警钟，同时播下骚乱和不和的种子，对立派系的领袖们争斗不是为了革命的事业
than for the power to rule in the monarch's name. And when I see these things, I don't believe the revolution is over. And once again, he is speaking truth to power. That's it. And when he finishes, when he goes out, there are loads of crowds waiting for him and they carry him through the streets. Hurrah for Robespierre. You know, he's speaking for the people once again. So that's one shadow. And the other shadow is in the Tuileries Palace because... Fibbers, fibbers, fibbers, fibbers. Barnard has been completely double-crossed. Louis and Marie Antoinette have absolutely no intention of working with this new constitution. All the time, Marie Antoinette has been sending secret messages to Vienna.
而是为了以君王的名义统治的权力。当我看到这些时，我不相信革命已经结束。又一次，他在向权势说出真相。就是这样。当他结束发言，当他走出去时，有大批群众在等他，他们把他抬着穿过街道。罗伯斯庇尔万岁。你知道，他再次为人民发声。所以这是一个阴影。另一个阴影在杜伊勒里宫，因为……骗子，骗子，骗子，骗子。巴纳夫被彻底出卖了。路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特根本无意与这部新宪法合作。玛丽·安托瓦内特一直在向维也纳发送秘密信息。
And she has been saying to her Austrian family, these people are brutes. They are madmen. She writes to her brother and she says explicitly, we are going along with Bonaventure, quote, the better to double cross them later. Louis writes to the Austrian emperor, Leopold II, I am a prisoner. I am under duress. I beg you to come to the aid of the king and the kingdom of France. So given that he is the center of this new constitution. He's the king of the French now, isn't he?
她一直在对她的奥地利家人说，这些人是野蛮人。他们是疯子。她写信给她的弟弟，明确表示，我们顺从巴纳夫，引用原话，“以便以后更好地背叛他们”。路易写信给奥地利皇帝利奥波德二世，我是一个囚犯。我是在胁迫下。我恳求你来援助国王和法兰西王国。鉴于他是这部新宪法的心脏。他现在是法国人的国王了，不是吗？
Not the king of France. Yeah. And he's asking a foreign king to attack his own people. Now, Tom, there's one thing we've had missing from this episode that listeners to season one will have undoubtedly noticed. There's been no Simon Sharma. So we should end with a little bit, because it wouldn't be a Restless History of French Revolution episode without Simon Sharma. Simon Sharma writes at the end of his chapter on
不是法兰西国王。是的。而且他正在请求一个外国国王去攻击他自己的国民。现在，汤姆，这集里有一点我们遗漏了，第一季的听众无疑会注意到。没有西蒙·沙玛。所以我们应该以一点关于他的内容结束，因为如果没有西蒙·沙玛，那就不是一期精彩的法国大革命播客。西蒙·沙玛在他的章节末尾写道
this. Poets of romantic weather forecasting like William Wordsworth continued to describe the revolution as a very cyclonic disturbance. But increasingly, it was no longer the storm that invigorates and cleanses, rather a dark and potent elemental rage moving forward in indiscriminate destruction its breath was no longer sweet but foul it was the wind of war and if the wind of war comes can the storm clouds of war be far behind so dominic brilliant. What a cliffhanger. And in our next episode, France will indeed be going to war. And if you can't wait for that, then you can hear the episode right away by joining the Restless History Club at therestesshistory.com. So thanks, Dominic.
威廉·华兹华斯等浪漫主义天气预报员继续将革命描述为一次气旋式扰动。但渐渐地，它不再是那种令人振奋和涤荡的风暴，而是一种黑暗而强烈的元素之怒，在无差别的毁灭中向前推进，它的气息不再甜美，而是恶臭难闻，那是战争之风，如果战争之风到来，战争的风暴云还会远吗？所以，多米尼克，太精彩了。真是个悬念。在我们的下一集里，法国确实将走向战争。如果你等不及了，那么你可以立即加入the-restlesshistory.com上的“起底历史俱乐部”来收听这一集。谢谢你，多米尼克。
Thank you all for listening. Bye-bye. Au revoir the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家的聆听。再见。再见。落幕娱乐，我们告诉你这一切是如何运作的，我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告聆听、额外节目和现场门票的抢先购买权，本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。